hello I have this video playing Jerome
yep so let's see what we get here I
don't really remember what I got against
him earlier so I'm trying yes a Michigan
which i recently lost with from a nice
position d65 hmm it's also interesting d
5 is going to go for again so I play you
for why not okay let's and focus here so
we're kind of 3mm click on each 4-year
age 44 later g4 like full-scale attack
now you might take on d4 and play civ 5
actually that could be an issue
night h7 maybe he tried to attack aged
for ad it's a bit maybe it's a bit too
aggressive in what I'm doing go he
allows this really amazing so each five
then he goes back or I can also take it
take it why not take 22
or maybe this year with the tempo it's
not bad f6 is rather questionable I
think taking and taking away their and
cover of that night the protection of
retinoid so
you an f4 might be a move I come on it
kind of fits the whole the whole
procedure here
f5 h5 root g 1 root g6 kind of that this
kind of thing would be nice to get I
probably not go to happen
yeah looks like a tough defense for
black
yeah are probably going to Castle long
it's not something that you see often in
this opening in general in the names
though we don't see that often okay but
I'm not really calculating much yet it's
kind of unclear what is movers
one idea also is like f5 and then 93
night h5 it's not not a bad idea
you really not sure what is movers him
or is he just disconnected too I mean
sometimes you know sometimes you really
want our care what what what is it what
is he doing here what what is he coming
up with and then you find out okay it's
just a disconnection so let's go here 93
or
93 interesting really a special chief
form i scoop g8 hi that's not that lets
not clear this position maybe this one
so king of two
maybe I should have played 93 my ideas
Bishop b2 traded and go to h5 if
possible
so you go into double maybe hmm double
on the chief al said something
I defended that really well we should at
least at least the fields like it Queen
III is just I don't know what to do move
it should be to chair we should be true
what he doesn't he doesn't exchange
somebody simply doesn't trade I mean age
5 is bad I may I can take e five and try
to grab a seven which looks very cheeky
come on that's probably a really bad
idea but in order to exploit something
on the queenside he has to move stuff
away from the G file so maybe this is
not as it you're together it looks hey
looks valid your take to grab the pawn
b6 conceived 5d five maybe okay I'm just
going back
yeah now maybe now I can do something
there there should be two jigs I still
don't get get them okay let's keep this
pawn for the moment it's not just the
part it's him entering this is what
irritates here ok and now maybe up for
night h5 known i th 5s is in them takes
chinks in ith five yes time one in there
that's okay I get through to you on that
stuff night h5 check oh I didn't see
that one that yes you for it takes you
form chance here this is Quinn def one
coming oh my god I hope I'm not running
into some sick made here okay look here
threads up to seven it's a nice little
tactic yep purchase a check who check
check
black forfeits on time wow wow I the
opening I know I looked it looked like I
looked very very shaky from black but I
couldn't couldn't really prove it this
is this may be a force rubbish that when
looking at the game it probably is
rubbish right because that Bishop g4
defense was really really annoying at
least I couldn't do anything against it
the engine just wants to do this and
look G 1 I had an experiment I think
this is a really good defense he took a
very long time but he played as well f
537 yeah he had yet here to compared a
very good defensive set up and if
anybody could do something it was
certainly black like hear this ok again
now this is probably super risky ok the
computer points out 98 that's
interesting and quite get it yet 23 9
p-6 and then a day we move her wince if
all right he just went c3 as your forum
yeah and that was super risky but I
didn't want to want to shuffle around 95
again was good and this is all good for
him now it was too risky and whenever he
gets one porn back and enters into my
position mikey is also very open yeah
now I'm in fact chatter oh no King f3
the same mating idea the same meeting
idea that i saw later that is so later
of course he cannot take here he cannot
take it's the same major Jesse made that
we had later in the game check so here
root g one is still ok for black seems
to be a draw check this and I walked you
to win Sam yeah he this is Ruby seven
threat and if he defense this I wanted
to go g6 actually the computer gives
Queen a tube which is very mysterious
for me maybe quick six or something I
don't get it I would have done this move
Queen evade okay and kind of holds Queen
a two wice what is the smooth
hmm and the engine says wide winds
basically this is what so mystifying
once to play night to d8 whoo okay let's
say we do that rook g6 the Angelus just
doing this this like let's trade and
take f6 next two plus three amazingly
very very tough game okay thanks for
watching